ce sera la mémoire durable d'un
sacrifice
le premier médecin français victimes au
travail de l'épidémie de kobe 19
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
cette fraise que cette oeuvre finalement
de notre ami jean jacques décédés ni
plus ni moins que senghor le symbole de
notre grand corps médical entièrement
réunies bienveillant et engagé au
service des autres et pour les malades
[Musique]
mm
nous sommes
je
m
l'ailé quelqu'un de fait simples à de
très chaleureux et qui est mis aussi
j'avais la joie de vivre est passionné
par son travail
jean-jacques était un homme d'une très
grande humanité d'un altruisme sans
faille au service des autres en toutes
circonstances malheureusement jusqu au
sacrifice de sa vie
cette phrase que représente l'ensemble
des professionnels mobilisés dans cette
lutte contre le virus
ému et honoré qui d une reconnaissance
de ce qu'il a dit si on va du talent
mais je pense que lui il est beaucoup
plus jeune
nous nous
m
le
on n'est pas là pour polémiquer mais
peut-être que si l'équipement avait été
présent on va dire en temps et en heure
on n'aurait peut-être pas de liste si
longue a déploré de soignants tombé à
cause du torride non c'est pas normal
c'est sa vocation c'était de sauver des
gens de guérir des malades mais pas lui
deux de mourir
les soignants et le corps médical et
l'ensemble des agents travaillant
effectivement son nom quand même
maintenant nettement mieux protégés que
pendant la période aiguë du printemps
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]